I think the biggest issue that we're
having is that Jessie story felt
believable we all know Jessie we were
shocked by what happened we tried to be
supportive and the thing is is that at
the end of the day the law is a law and
he will have his day in court and we all
have to contend to that I'm praying for
Justin and his family for me this speaks
to the power of prayer
there was no way this could stay
secretive hidden in a dishonourable or
dishonest way because so many people
were praying I'm heartbroken for his
family I am heartbroken that there's
something within Jessie that felt if he
was lacking that though he needed more
but we cannot in our humanity stop
loving stop believing celebs speak out
at the essence black women in Hollywood
Awards the same day Jessie Smollett
faced the court on a felony charge for
allegedly filing a false police report
the Empire star has since posted bond
right now we are really living through
some perilous times and I know everyone
wants to hear from you about the Jessie
case I mean how are you absorbing
everything as it unraveled I'm listening
and I'm trying to think through what
causes one to make certain kinds of
decisions but I am waiting for the final
outcome of all of this and if in fact it
is a hoax
I'm disappointed if not I will be
overjoyed to learn that it was not what
we think it is
as of today or we heard that it is up
today and if in fact Jessie has harmed
his career
he'll pay a big price for it what words
do you have
now that the Jessie small interest has
happened
don't jump to conclusions we live in a
Crime and Punishment society but we pick
and choose the crimes we pay attention
to and the punishment we meet out if he
did was the bottom line is he told a lot
but the leader of our country tells one
every day if he did this it means that
he's in some kind of pain that when
ignored this happens every day in every
woman and every family in every
community that we don't pay attention to
each other's pain you're someone that
has spearheaded so many big
conversations especially with the meets
a little bit
what teachable moment can we learn from
justice Millette space right now well
you know I think we've always been clear
that we believe survivors we need to
maintain that one isolated incident
doesn't change the reality that sexual
violence and deeply pervasive and most
survivors are telling the truth no
matter where the truth lies the point is
is that there are people in this country
who are magnet supporters who do hate
black and gay people do you think you
would ever have them on your show six my
life
not fixing my life this is not a fixable
plan what I would love to do is have a
conversation so that we get an
opportunity to identify with how we do
this because if it's in the chair it's
in the room meaning if one person is
doing doing in hundreds of thousands of
doing it and this is an opportunity for
us to really practice what we preach
about forgiveness and redemption and all
of that
[Music]
[Applause]